on the new TV ad touch 9 tips that
Street Fighter 5 tutorial won't teach
you number one find your go-to moves hit
up training mode so you can learn your
characters go-to moves that control
vertical and horizontal space find your
folks and anti-air worry about combos
later bind your cross ups for more
damage opportunities study each of your
characters moves and learn how to apply
them to specific situations
number two is combo bread-and-butter a
crucial part of any fighting game is
maximizing damage often opportunity but
if you don't have the muscle memory to
execute the harder ones stick with the
basics the bread-and-butter this is your
staple combo something you can perform
consistently and does decent damage
every character has one number three Max
or consistent damage don't always go
from max damage combos spacing and
potential opportunities for damage after
the combo may be more advantageous for
example instead of going for max damage
off a single opportunity you choose to
execute a combo that pushes the opponent
to the corner in the corner the
potential for consistent damage from
cross ups and wakeup pains and resets is
greater than the single max damage
opportunity number for hitting 101 don't
always attack up close use short and
long range attack strategies don't feel
compelled that your attacks should
always make contact with the opponent
beginners make the mistake of taking the
fight directly in front of your opponent
for the entire round whipping fast
attack to different ranges has its
advantages first the space controls by
the width move may stop your opponent's
attacks second it may prevent the
opponent from advancing into your space
number 5 situational a round is a series
of moment-to-moment situations and each
situation presents a problem and a
solution most situations have an answer
but knowing and responding to them
properly takes time and experience for
example a common situation is your
opponent jumping in on you the solution
use your and tires the opponent landing
a lot of counter hits on you stop trying
to attack after you block and serve your
movement number 6 use everything
Oh mostly your moves are an extension of
yourself use them not just for damage
but for answers to specific situations I
made the mistake of relying on strong
attacks our punch and heartache over
weaker ones like light punch and light
kick I wanted to hurt the opponent by
capitalizing on every opportunity with
the most damage but this just restricts
your game your normals and special moves
are more than just tools were damaged
they can be applied to a number
situations restricting your opponent's
options or asking them by constant
sticking out something in their space or
stuffing their attacks number seven the
rhythm avoid falling into a predictable
rhythm by using a set pattern do
something unexpected even crazy to throw
off your opponent's mindset a pattern
has a predictable rhythm for example
mindlessly chucking fireballs without
changing your timing or position is a
pattern easily exploitable by your
opponent in this case stepping a few
paces back before throwing a barbell or
pausing for every second is enough to
change the rhythm number eight pattern
recognition recognizing patterns
strengthens your ability to adapt to
anticipate and to have a quick answer
for a disadvantaged situation rhythm is
important role encounter recognition the
required skill for any competitive game
by recognizing patterns you can come up
with an answer to the obstacle stay one
step ahead of your opponent number nine
fear just being in someone's immediate
space is enough to manipulate their
behavior when people are scared they'll
either fight or flee in fighting games
this means you're probably jump back
and/or walk away from the opponent or
hit a bunch of buttons to get the
opponent out of your surrounding space
use this to influence your opponent's
decision-making process
the mechanic can change your strategy
commit dumb errors or crumble under
pressure
whoa that's a lot of info to digest
learning the fundamentals takes time and
executing them without hesitation is an
exercise in patience but the payoff will
be well worth it
you
you